as covet cases increase so does the
concern about the biggest convention in
las vegas coming up in january we're
talking about ces that's right well
sally haramiya reports some companies
are choosing not to participate in
person due to safety
nevada governor steve siselek responds
to reports that some companies are
pulling out of ces i was disappointed to
see some companies a couple companies
pulled out of ces
hopefully that there won't be a lot more
according to brian gordon principal with
applied analysis the massive electronics
convention helps our economy the last 22
months have been a little bit different
than
our normal historical trend lines it's
important for our tourism industry and
we're hopeful that people will continue
to visit las vegas those dollars that
ultimately translate into jobs are
critical about a third of the overall
job base in southern nevada is tied
directly to
the travel and tourism industry and the
convention sector within leisure and
hospitality is really a key component
gordon adds that with time we will get
back to pre-pandemic levels there are
going to be some setbacks as we move
along but you know to date i think the
overall recovery has been much better
than most of us had expected when we
were sitting here in march of 2020. the
giant tech show with over 2100
exhibitors is set to begin on wednesday
january 5th through saturday january 8th
with vaccine and mass requirements it's
one of the reasons you need to get a
vaccine is to protect our economy sally
jaramillo live local now
thank you sally well the consumer
technology association released a
statement indicating there's been 42
exhibitors cancelling canceling over the
past week but there were also 60 new
exhibitors added for the in-person event